both young Oh Kurt has taken up the
fight against cancer the researcher at
Berlin's max delbrück center for
molecular medicine is developing a
promising weapon in that battle it's
based on a major element of the immune
system known as T cells in a viral
infection a t-cell recognizes signs of
the invader based on its surface
characteristics and eliminates it but
cancerous cells like the one here in
black aren't destroyed because they're
derived from our own healthy cells here
in blue the t-cell doesn't recognize the
cancer cell as a danger the researchers
in Kurt's group carry out experiments to
identify precisely what distinguishes
cancer cells from healthy ones in
specific patients they want to help the
t-cell identify and attack tumors while
leaving other cells alone for that they
modify receptors on T cells armed with a
new key the T cells begin to latch onto
the surface of the tumor cell the
engineered T cells are tested first in
cell cultures then in animals to see how
effectively they attack cancer cells the
aim is to use them one day in human
cancer patients is an oil formed a point
in this newer form of immunotherapy
which targets specific differences
between cancer cells and normal cells is
designed to exclusively destroy cancer
cells the therapy is exclusive in
another way to the scientists want to
customize it to each individual patient
mine called villain a truly does of
course my dream would be to use this
research for as many types of tumors as
possible and i hope this immunotherapy
and i think you don't have to be a
prophet to see it coming will become a
real alternative to radiation and
chemotherapy the method is still
expensive to implement however and
tailoring it to each individual patient
and tumor type takes time
but the researchers are optimistic that
these problems can be overcome and that
in the future immunotherapy using
modified t-cells could play a big role
in the fight against cancer